so the important thing is the media
reaction to this because the media drive
the narrative and if that narrative is
that america is a deeply racist place
and every incident they will just lie
about in order to reinforce that
narrative that drives bad policy making
decisions by the public because if you
believe that america is a deeply racist
place and that disparities in for
example criminal populations between
black and white are solely due to
american racism you're more likely to
elect a progressive prosecutor who puts
criminals back out on the street in the
name of equity
and the media are just botching the
story and they're not just botching it i
mean because remember this story is over
we've known all the facts in this case
for a year but we really know him now
cause the case is over and we saw all
the evidence presented at trial by the
prosecution it doesn't matter the media
have their case and they're pressing it
forward and they are lying about it like
openly lying the detroit free press
said on sunday quote in august 2020
jacob blake was shot and killed by a
police officer in kenosha wisconsin he's
not dead
the hell are you talking about that's
not even true okay in the media are
repeating stuff like this
there's a paper in the uk that reported
that kylo ren has to chat and had shot
three black people all three of the
people he shot were white
meanwhile you have msnbc's tiffany cross
going on national television calling
written house a quote little murderous
white supremacist
the fact that white supremacists roam
the halls of congress freely and
celebrate this little murderous white
supremacist and the fact that he gets to
walk the streets freely it lets you know
these people have access to instituting
laws they represent the legislative
branch of this country what are we to
make of that
well i hope that she enjoys the
defamation lawsuit that's what we ought
to make of that little murderous white
supremacist
she doesn't have
every word that she says there is untrue
he is not a white supremacist and he is
not a murderer by the law so i hope that
she really enjoys her summons for the
for the defamation lawsuit for the
subpoena that that'll be that'll be fun
to preserve all of her papers and all
this meanwhile cnn's van jones says we
now have a pattern of white vigilantes
again the narrative must be upheld at
all costs it is very important for the
left to uphold this narrative
this idea of
white vigilante violence is something
that we have to wrestle with and it may
not be
be done in one single court case but
we've got a pattern now
where white men feel that they have the
right to enforce the law themselves when
you look at ahmad arbury uh when you
look at this case uh when you look at
trayvon martin when you look at the
white mob that attacked the capitol that
somehow
there's a group of people that think
that they have the right to take the law
into their own hands they can leave
their home with guns and they can
enforce their vision of the law on other
people
he was not enforcing his vision of the
law on other people he literally shot
these people in self-defense he was
attacked okay but the narrative has to
be maintained it's white vigilantism
that's white racism white supremacy
amber ruffin who i'd never heard of
until she started being pushed on
twitter
she apparently has a show on peacock
which i guess is nbc's online wing
and and here she goes
it's not okay
for a man
to grab a rifle
travel across state lines
and shoot three people and then walk
free
it's not okay for the judicial system
to be blatantly and obviously stacked
against people of color
it's not okay
for there to be an entirely different
set of rules
for white people
but uh i don't care about cal
rittenhouse i don't care about that
racist judge and i don't care about how
that jury must be
uh white people have been getting away
with murder since time began i don't
care about that i care about you
and uh i can't believe i have to say
this but you matter
okay this sort of rhetoric is uh is
horrifying it's horrifying because it's
a lie so first of all he didn't cross
state lines of the gun second of all he
didn't just shoot people
third the people who shot were white
fourth self-defense is a defense that
applies to everyone black white and
green
fifth the notion that she doesn't care
about kyle rittenhouse is obviously
untrue she's crying about it on national
tv so no
but again this is the narrative the
narrative is
any story can be twisted to fit this
narrative that america is a white
supremacist country and therefore you
have to give power to radicals in order
to
in order to fix the problem and this
bleeds over into every area of our
culture remember it is a wave okay so as
i wrote in my book the authoritarian
moment the authoritarianism is coming
from from the institutions it is coming
from the institutions the left only
wants to talk about january 6th this
notion the idea that the democracy is
about to be overthrown every major
institution in american life is lying to
you right now about cases like kyle
rittenhouse every major institution in
american life is lying to you about
criminality every major institution in
american life is willing to twist the
fact and falsify the fact and then to
penalize you if you refuse to go along
with it to suspend you if you refuse to
go along with it to fire you if you
refuse to go along with it
you will be plunking that black lives
matter sign down on your lawn or you
will lose your job
you will definitely not express any
support for for a kyle written house's
defense
or you will lose your job
you will not maintain that america is
not systemically racist or you will lose
your job that is what these folks want
and they will lie to get what they want
and again it's every area it's not just
you know your media which is of course
just a propaganda wing for the
democratic party
it's it's cultural figures like reese
witherspoon
i'm old enough to remember when when the
spoon wasn't entirely politically insane
but now she tweets out crap like this
quote woke up this morning thinking
about every mother father sister brother
friend who's lost someone to senseless
gun violence in america and then there
was no justice for their pain this is a
disgrace justice for for whose pain
the child molester attempting to grab a
gun from a minor
or the guy trying to slam a skateboard
into the head of a miner or the guy
approaching somebody with a gun to shoot
him which one of those people reese hey
how about mark buffalo
mark ruffalo's just my god mark ruffalo
he tweeted out we come together to mourn
the lives lost to the same racist system
that devalues black lives none of these
three people were black none of them
they were all whiter than i am
we come together says mark ruffalo to
mourn the lives lost to the same racist
system that devalues black lives and
devalued the lives of anthony and jojo
who the f is jojo is he spot is jojo
referring to joseph rosenbaum a
convicted pedophile
is he literally referring to a convicted
pedophile who used the n-word that night
and tried to chase down a guy to kill
him as jojo
maria shriver tweeted out i'm trying to
take a beat to digest the rittenhouse
verdict my son just asked me how it's
possible he didn't get charged for
anything how is that possible i don't
have an answer for him well first of all
he was charged with stuff he was then
acquitted
also your son is 26 at some point you
might want to tell him that he is
capable of turning on a television
um
also
are you maria trying to take a beat to
digest the written house verdict how is
it possible that he didn't get charged
for anything uh last i checked your name
is maria
kennedy shriver
right like you're you are like you're
part of the
kennedy family
right and you're and teddy
drove a woman into the drink and left
her there to drown and then sat in
senate for several terms so i'm going to
go shh
on this one
you might want to like yeah cool in on
this one
but again it's every area of the culture
jaylen rose covering the nba talking
about cal written house
we want to know why we're launching into
sports here at daily wire one of the
reasons we're launching this sport so
you have to watch garbage like this from
jalen rose
here's the thing
the black lives matter protest
was actually taking place because jacob
blake was shot and killed by police
officers
jacob blake is alive
it's just incredible it's just
incredible and by the way again this is
all mirroring the democratic party
political position
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video